this racial political narrative as the
as the dominant thread in western
politics it's true in britain too on a
completely different sort of story but
this the same theme here
a british dance school
has just dropped ballet from its
audition process
and it's dropped ballet from the
audition process because it's quote
built around white european ideas
britain
historically one of the whitest
countries ever
is not allowed to have ballet
at its dance school
because ballet is too white
one
non-white people can dance ballet last i
checked but two why are
why are why are white dances terrible
why are we not allowed to have white
dances britain's north northern school
of contemporary dance dropped ballet
from that process because not only is it
too white
and european but it's too gendered as
well and this is being reported by the
telegraph it's got a potentially
contentious nature here is what
the head of undergraduate studies at the
dance school says it is essentially an
elitist form young people need to pay to
take ballet classes as a general rule
and for a vast number of potential
students they've not had access to
ballet and so we've got to get rid of
ballet when we're considering who should
come into the dance school
and she's saying it's elitist you have
to pay you have to train it requires a
lot of skill and so we've got to get rid
of that
one the argument is kind of racist right
they're saying oh this thing that
requires a lot of skill and time and
effort and it's really beautiful and
intricate and sophisticated yeah that's
just for white people that's just for
white view all the non-white people they
can just kind of stomp around without
any skill whatsoever that's fine for
them but we you know listen here we we
we're so progressive we're so woke that
we're going to get rid of all of the
sophisticated beautiful dancers because
those are clearly just for white people
the black people could never dance
ballet that's crazy crazy talk don't you
think so there is a kind of irony here
that they are embodying the very thing
that they're pretending to attack but
two
i like ballet i like nice things i like
things that require skill i like things
that require training i don't think that
only white people can do things that
require skill and training and that are
beautiful
why is it
that in the name of racial equity
we have to bring everything down
why can't we bring everyone up i have
faith that we can bring people up
regardless of their race i have faith
that we can
train people and teach and teach people
to look for the good the true and the
beautiful and do all the sorts i i have
faith that that can happen i think i
think there's quite quite a lot of
evidence that that has happened in the
past
what here though is they say nope sorry
because of racism you don't
because of racial politics you no longer
get ballet i think this really doesn't
play for the libs who are pushing it i
in the long run it's been an effective
strategy for them
but
when people see it too clearly when when
in the short run when they go a little
too far a little too fast there's a huge
amount of backlash
i mean you're getting this right now you
can see you don't have to take my word
for it you're seeing it in the public
opinion polls and you're not just a
public opinion folks but public opinion
polls from the libs one of the national
teachers unions
just did a battleground state survey
uh asking what people thought about ron
desantis education policy positions and
specifically on critical race theory
racial lessons in schools and they
realized this stuff is a total loser
by a 32 percentage point margin
the poll said a voters rather in the
poll said that they were more likely to
vote for candidates who believe public
schools should focus less on teaching
race
and more on core subjects 32 points
that's a poll
pushed by the libs by 27 points voters
said schools should be banned from
teaching sexual orientation and gender
identity to kids in kindergarten through
third grade which like duh of course
it's pathetic that we even need to frame
the question that way
fourth graders let's you know teach them
about ball gags and puppy play with sam
brinton and the rest of the weirdos in
our national sexual uh revolution
but no no but third grade that's a
little too young and then by 28
percentage points
they say that transgender athletes
should be banned from competing in girls
sports
this is an obvious loser
for
the libs
and it's why desantis is being talked
about as
a major republican presidential
candidate for 2024 if not
very nearly the presumptive nominee
trump really throws a wrench into all of
those plans but desantis is being talked
about
in at the presidential level in a way
that i have rarely seen candidates
talked about and it's because he's just
doubling down on this
message he did it again earlier this
month
you can't put a price tag on opportunity
for kids and making sure parents uh have
the ability and of course separate from
the budget you know we believe that when
parents send their kids to school it's
for education not for indoctrination and
we're going to hold that line in florida
now this line literally
is is not the most meaningful line in
the world when people say this it's for
education not for indoctrination
they're really saying we support my kind
of education not their kind of education
education and indoctrination mean
essentially the same thing it's just
that one has a positive connotation and
one has a negative connotation it's a
little more complex than that because
education involves uh freeing people up
making them more human teaching them to
make sense of their freedom and their
rational will whereas indoctrination is
considered less thoughtful
and you know more akin to brainwashing
but
broadly speaking what we're really
talking about is the substance here no
we think kids should be taught good and
true things and they shouldn't be taught
critical race theory and weird sex stuff
and puppy play and transgenderism that's
that's what we're really saying but i
get why ron desantis is using the line i
think it's a very effective line it is
true that slogans are always wrong and
shallow and they can never get to the
entirety of of a political view
but
you know when you're in politics you've
got to use slogans that's politics is
made of slogans and ron desantis has hit
on a good one and when you look at what
that means in practice for ron desantis
he's done an excellent job on the issue
and the libs are losing on that issue
right now head on over to epicwill.com
use code knowles because you will die
i have news for you my friend you will
die do you go skydiving you will die do
you breathe oxygen you will die no one
here gets out alive not in this world my
friends
so you need to have a will okay a will
is not about you it's about your loved
ones it's about the really difficult
decisions they will face if something
happens to you excuse me when something
happens to you do yourself a favor do
your family a favor make those decisions
now so that they don't have to face them
later without you epic will makes it so
so easy to get your affairs in order i
just finished up my will about a month
or so ago epic will is taking care of a
ton of people here at the daily wire go
to epicwell.com use promo code knowles
k-w-l-e-s save 10
on epic will's complete package right
now you can get a will in as little as
five minutes super duper easy well worth
119 bucks to secure your family's future
without a will you might as well wrap up
all your money and your assets and your
kids hand them over to the state do not
do that you probably don't want that to
happen right now go to
epicwill.com use code knowles take you
five minutes square away the rest of
your life and you can move on epic
will.com
code
knowles i'm glad you like that clip we
are about two people away from hitting a
million subscribers i don't know what
the actual number is but we are so close
to one million that's going to be great
they're going to send me a big gold play
button and then almost certainly they're
going to nuke my channel right they're
not going to let me get over a million
subscribers so let's do it baby let's
just let's go out in a blaze of glory
ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you